[Music]
mind in the making is the result of a
now 13-year journey where I set out to
find out what can we do to keep the fire
for learning burning in children's eyes
all young children are born with not
only a passion but a survival skill to
learn about the world that they live in
and yet far too many children and adults
have lost that passion have lost that
fire for the business community
engagement is one of the major
predictors of productivity and that's
what this is I wanted to understand this
by going out and talking to some of the
best researchers who understand brain
development who understand how we grow
and how we change I ended up finding
that there are these life skills that
emerge in all of us but we don't pay
very much attention to promoting them we
think of learning as the content of what
we learned but we don't think of
learning as the how we learn and what
life skills are are the how that we
learn they interestingly enough all
involve what researchers call executive
functions of the brain and I know that
sounds like a guy in a pinstripe suit
bossing you around in your brain but
what these are are the capacities that
take place in our prefrontal cortex that
pull together our social our emotional
and our cognitive capacities that enable
us to achieve our goals basically mind
in the making describes the research
behind these executive function life
skills and then talks about how we can
promote them in ourselves and in the
children in our lives a very important
life skill is focused in self-control we
live in a world that's full of
distractions and yet if we're going to
achieve our goals and remember all life
skills are based around
setting goals and achieving them for
ourselves if we're going to achieve our
goals we need to be able to pay
attention attention and not go on
automatic focus and self-control
involves being able to pay attention it
involves being able to remember all the
things that we need to know to achieve
the goal that we have it involves the
flexibility to be able to adapt as as
life changes and again the control not
to go on automatic but do what we need
to do to achieve a goal perspective
taking is understanding what might be
going on in someone else's mind it's
understanding how that person thinks how
that person feels and how that person
sees the world an intellectual a social
and an emotional understanding of the
landscape of other people's minds and
it's very important to deal with other
people if we don't think that what we
think is the only way that that it you
know that's the only reality it's very
important to understand other people's
realities as well communicating is
thinking through what it is you want to
communicate and then understanding the
perspectives of other people who are
going to be the recipients they're going
to be the people who listen to or
understand what each other says it's
it's critical in business for example to
understand what your customers need and
want it's critical in any family
relationships to understand what other
people think and feel but then to
communicate in ways that reach them best
you could call communicating and they do
this in the business world the elevator
speech if you only had a minute in an
elevator with someone and you that
person is really important to something
that you want to do what would you say
to be able to get through to that person
that's what communicating really is
making connections is symbolic
relationships understanding what things
go together what things are alike what
things are different and how they might
go together in fact making unusual
connections is the basis of creativity
so important in our world
where you can google for information are
the people who can put things together
in different ways critical thinking is a
very important skill because
particularly today we're awash in
information you could go on the internet
and find six different versions of you
know what if you're not feeling well
what's really going on with you or even
understanding a so-called fact there is
so much information and we have to have
the capacity to understand what is valid
and what is reliable information that's
the basis of critical thinking taking on
challenges is more than a coping with
stress a life can be stressful no matter
how we plan for it no matter what we
want to do things happen to us that we
don't like and we have to be able to
cope with those things but taking on
challenges goes beyond simply coping
with the things that happen to us it
means taking on that next harder thing
and if you think about a world in which
information is changing constantly we
are going to have to do things today or
tomorrow that we didn't even know
existed yesterday so we have to have the
ability to take on the challenge and try
something hard even and failing as a
part of learning you know being able to
fail but learn from the failures is all
part of taking on challenges
self-directed engaged learning is the
ability to continue to learn from life
to learn from our experience to have the
initiative to learn in ways that we can
use the information that we have so
really all of the life skills all of the
executive function life skills add up to
helping us be ongoing learners because
again in a world where information
changes so rapidly it is the ongoing
learners who will thrive I invite you to
join me in this workshop where we're
going to take a deeper look at the seven
essential life skills and we're going to
look at some video clips really straight
from the researchers labs so that you
can go
in to the lab of a neuro scientist or a
cognitive scientist or someone else who
studies our development particularly
among children and look at how we know
what we know and then look at how to
apply these life skills to your own life
[Music]